hello everybody I'm Grandmaster Robert
hungaski and uh I'm going to be doing a
lecture for you guys today and in this
lecture I'm going to be talking about uh
some games some of my games some more my
more recent games
some of them not too bad some of them
terrible uh
but let's start easy and um let's start
with a game that I can actually explain
what I did
and this is a game from the recently
finished Continental Championship was
held in the Dominican Republic just a
couple weeks ago
now
it's a tournament where I had a rocky
start and even rockier finish but in the
middle it seemed like things might turn
out okay
and this was kind of like at at my best
moment and uh it was a game that I was
playing with white against a talented
young player from Colombia
who was having a phenomenal tournament
so far you've beaten a couple of GM's
couple of draws seemed on track
for the GM Norm uh so it's a very
dangerous game and I decided to approach
approach it cautiously with the move
Knight F3 so move Knight F3 I remember
when I was my opponent's age around 16
or so was the move that uh annoyed me
the most because it's the most flexible
the one that reveals the least
information so you know I haven't really
made it clear uh
to Black you know how far my d-pawn is
going to go is this going to be a queen
Pawn it's going to be a ready in English
if C5 I might even still uh transpose
back to King Pawn
so the interesting thing about Knight F6
is that
if you're a D4 player it's a nice back
door to a lot of Queen Pawn positions
without all the queen Pawn theory for
example you know you avoid most of the
Indian defenses for example the
groomfeld
is kind of out right if you go Bishop G7
I will allow a king's Indian so you know
if you don't like playing against the
king's Indian you basically should never
be playing D4
um
and if you're a D4 player facing the
king's Indian should seem like Christmas
every time
so the king's Indian okay that's that's
fine groomfeld is out that's huge
another big one nimzo Indian right so
now uh this is actually how the game
went I played G3 and if you're an Enzo
Indian player you know you're you're
just uh
hitting thin air if you play Bishop B4
so
Knight F3 is a great way of avoiding the
groomfeld the nimso Indian the benoni
the benko gamut I mean all of these
nightmare openings that are just
labyrinths within themselves so uh it's
a very practical way of playing now of
course black instead of playing Knight
F6 could go D5
and as a knight of three player this is
you know what you look at as the most
serious challenge because I remember
many years ago I played at um Blitz
tournament in Philadelphia it's like the
world open Blitz tournament and they got
paired against Wesley so
and I figured hey I'm gonna play nice
quiet game gonna start with Knight F3
and I'll move two I just felt like I was
already getting uh put under pressure
because he played this move d4 and and
usually the most challenging approach is
by black against Knight F3 are going to
involve black saying hey you know you
you had your chance to play D4
and you let it pass you by now I'm gonna
take the Reigns of the game and I'm
gonna put a Pawn on D4 so
that thread is very important all
throughout Knight F3 and you're like
ready in English opening so by the way
um that game if I recall correctly went
G3 Knight C6 Bishop G2
E5
Castle kingside
E4 and already I had no idea what was
going on I was like well this looks okay
because I'll just go 91 threatening the
pawn and if he defends it with something
like Knight F6 I'll just keep chipping
away at it right so perfect
of course black played H5 immediately
and after you know something like takes
H4 D3 Bishop H3 followed by Queen D7
castles I would later come to find out
this was actually all Theory and it has
been played
um but it is not only just a tremendous
um variation for black
but
also illustrative of some of the dangers
that white faces and these seemingly
safe openings where were fiance right
the fianchetto for all its virtues has
important vulnerabilities uh mainly I
would say there are three
uh
three pillars that we need to knock down
for the fianchetto to collapse and that
would be number one driving away the
natural defender of the king side so
driving away the F3 Knight once that's
accomplished taking advantage of the
hook created by the G3 pawn and lastly
trading off the light Square Bishops I
mean if we can get those three things in
there then the fianchetto starts
um becoming more of a weakness than
anything else and we're going to talk
about a couple of different concepts
that we think of as strong
but that also have a downside right so
the fiancado is definitely one of those
structures
uh
so most of the time when I see the move
D5 I'll seriously consider saying hey
I've avoided all the infances I'm going
to take that as a as a moral win and I
will deal with D4 D5 openings in a more
traditional way
in any case my opponent did play Knight
F6 and after C4 played E6 so still kind
of hopeful that I'll play D4 which
didn't happen and now after G3
D5 Bishop G2 again another very ready
kind of moment because I could simply
transpose back to Queen pawn and play
Catalan with D4 but this
opens me up to
another wave of
Theory right and puts my opponent in a
privileged situation where he gets to
choose the course of the game now
because okay aside from all the D takes
C4 lines which I mean is just
there's so much I mean black can play
with C6 and B5 with Knight C6 uh with
Knight D7 with Bishop D7 Bishop C6
defense depending on you know whether
white goes Queen A4 or not
um the bishop can go to E7 or B4 I mean
you really need to know what you're
doing and I'm not really a specialist
and also recently I've been getting a
lot of games as black against the cattle
and and I've been exploring this move
Bishop be fortune and I think it's just
it's just great
um so very interesting
so
I didn't want to go into that so I just
played Bishop G2 and the point is if you
do go Bishop E7 now then I will play D4
because after D4 now D takes C4 loses a
little bit of its luster because
you've included the moves Bishop E7
Bishop G2 which I think is pretty clear
white is going to feel happier about
than black
and um
you know now for example if
well simply Queen A4 Queen takes C4 has
to be has to be fine
um these types of positions you have to
be very careful as black right you don't
want
to start clearing this diagonal because
this bishop gets progressively stronger
as pawns begin as black pawns begin to
disappear along this diagonal ideally we
just want to leave black with a Pawn on
B7 so
uh we won't really talk about Canal land
structures in this lecture but I will
be doing it in my next lecture because I
think it's so rich that you really have
to tackle it uh head on but this was the
type of Catalan that I was willing to go
into
but now my opponent reverts back to this
this this thread right I think this very
important attitude that black needs to
have and that is to say okay you know
enough of these move order tricks and
this ambiguity let's
Define what's really going to happen
like what kind of a game we're gonna
have and my opponent goes for it plays
D4
and after D4
tassels
C5 E3 I'm going to make these next
couple of moves kind of quickly because
uh they've been played many many times I
think after D3 we'll just take a quick
peek here
yeah it says
805 games in this position and that's
just the lead chest database I'm sure
maybe Mega database might have twice as
many games
um but anyway this is a topical position
and uh I remember many years ago
uh this this series of opening books
came out I think it was like play Knight
F3 like cram Nick and it was written by
Alexander hollifman and the books were
just like amazing for the time like I
built my entire Knight F3 repertoire
just just by doing exactly what the book
said and back then that kind of approach
worked pretty well and I learned a lot
about Knight F3
and um
I thought certain positions Knight F3
didn't look too great uh and this was
one of them I thought this was just a
very comfortable position for black and
I was worried
that people would start targeting what I
saw as this weakness in that repertoire
so I kind of dropped Knight F3 for a
while
and I was really worried about
going from solid to passive there's a
very fine line and I tended to fall off
that Cliff so I wasn't liking that and I
started playing this with black because
it's a very dynamic
ambitious way of playing against an
otherwise very solid
opening without really taking on that
much risk
so
my my latest understanding until maybe
last year was that this move was very
popular and I remember I had I had some
trouble
dealing with uh the move Bishop E7 for a
while I think
white was playing something like Knight
or A3 A5 Knight D2 castles and after
rookie one I remember losing Barry
convincingly in a game where my opponent
played 98 the simple idea of going F6
and E5
and this is going to be
the main thread of the game throughout
this structure because essentially what
we have here is a reversed benoni
structure if we
if we
talk about benoni structures it's useful
to know what the benoni is it's an
opening that black usually plays or not
so usually anymore
against Queen Pawn
um I think it's probably like the most
Reckless ambitious way of playing
against D4 it's just like whatever let's
let's get it over with like you're just
going for first round knockout type of
thing usually if you're a benoni player
and the game is dragging on and on and
on that's a bad sign so I say this
because I love the benoni I just I'm
going to keep playing it of course
but you you know you have to be able to
withstand some punishment
the games you win are a lot of fun the
games you lose just make you not want to
play the benoni anymore that's for sure
but it's a fascinating structure I mean
it's been played by Bobby Fischer
against spassky in their 72 match
um I mean tall played it
quite often
and you see it every now and then I mean
there's some 2700 players that use it
sometimes but it's essentially
um an outrageous opening so
the benoni structure
I mean there's so many ways that white
could play but just for the sake of
comparison right this would be your
typical benoni structure where
black has gone through great pains to
create
an asymmetrical position right now black
has this three against two
on the queen side and white is going to
have this two against one in the center
so White's going to try to break with E5
and Black's going to try to break with
B5 and and we're just going to be
swinging wildly at each other throughout
this whole time
now
in the position we got in the game
right after here there are some key
differences right being reversed you
know we have a benoni with an extra
tempo
but also this bishop is inside the pawn
chain instead of outside
that's not a big deal like uh it's it's
not a game changer in the benoni in fact
this game I was just referencing with
Bishop p7
castles usually after 98 F6 E5 you don't
know if The Bishop's coming to F5 might
go to E6 it might go to G4
so
I don't really remember why people
stopped playing Bishop E7 but there's
some there's some ideas I mean white can
play Knight A3 Knight C2 white can play
Rook actually very interesting
is to play rookie one and after castles
95 and start clearing the diagonal for
the bishop
and this is an interesting concept
uh variations aside
because
it's going to be what determines uh
the character of the game from now on I
mean this benoni structure basically
means that we have a game
that's about space right when black
plays this ambitious move d4
black is saying I'm grabbing the space
I'm going to play with a space Advantage
I'm going to have more space than you
and that implies something very
important which is
but this game is going to be about Minor
pieces that's what a space Advantage is
all about I mean don't let anybody fool
you the only thing that matters and the
only thing that determines whether space
Advantage is good or bad
are the minor pieces if you have space
you want to restrict your opponent's
minor pieces therefore you don't want to
trade them off you want your opponent to
feel cramped with them and not have
good squares to place those pieces in
right and that's what black strategy is
black wants to overrun us kind of like
how Wesley so overran me in that Blitz
game
well
that's what this is that's the tug of
war that's going to be going on in this
game so let's just move forward a couple
of moves
my opponent chooses this move Bishop D6
and hopefully this uh
little detour I took it's going to make
it easier to understand the move Bishop
G5 because this Pawn on D4 is a threat
to my minor pieces the last thing I
would want
for example let's say if I go A3 just
desperately gasping for air here with B4
Black's gonna go A5 let's say you know
Knight bd2 castles
um rookie one
E5 I'm making by the way terrible moves
for white even though they look kind of
natural this is not how you should play
uh the benoni if you can avoid it but
it's usually what's going to happen uh
and let's say I go Bishop G4 so I'm very
you know I'm having a very hard time
figuring out what the future of this
bishop is going to be
at the same time this Knight on F3 is
blocking my Bishop on G2 and it's not so
easy
to remove it because if I go something
like 94
then after Knight takes Rook takes it
starts becoming pretty clear
that
black is going to beat me to it black is
going to play E4 sooner than I'm gonna
play B4 let alone create any kind of a
threat right so if something like Rook
E1 Queen F6 rookie 8 and E4 are coming
and this is uh
pretty much a benoni massacre right so
the game is probably over by then
so that's what we want to avoid like if
if I have to fall into that kind of
position I'm out I don't want to play
this line but it turns out
that this extra Tempo that I have allows
me
to play this move and it's the most
liberating move in the benoni when you
get let's say it's black when you get to
trade off that Bishop you feel like oh
okay at least it's not going to be
terrible I I'm always going to have you
know room
so that's exactly how White's going to
feel after trading these Bishops and not
only that
let's say here I think we included A3 A5
or no it was Knight bd2 first and now if
Black's not careful
and allows me to trade off
another set of minor pieces
now it's not just relief now
we're in control as white because after
let's say A3 A5 after the move Knight D2
we have a dream benoni we've traded off
two sets of minor pieces we have perfect
harmony between the Knight and the
bishop nobody's getting in anybody's way
not only that the rook's gonna come to
you one beautifully the other rook's
gonna come to C1 and it's going to
support C5 and then I'll play Knight C4
and it's like all of the pieces are just
going to be dancing around each other
Without Really Ever bumping into each
other and that's really that's just what
you want in chess in general but in
these benoni structures when that
happens it's almost like everything like
a Tetris game where everything falls
perfectly into place so this is what
we're aiming for
therefore uh
black plays Queen E7 okay A3 A5 so that
after 94
black can play Bishop C7 and say Hey you
know enough of these trades now your
knight is going to pay the price because
my next moves are going to be castles E5
maybe bishop G4 F5 rookie 8 and E4 right
just
as a kind of rough sketch of the
position that's what it's going to look
like
so you know it might have been a bit
impulsive of me to to bring my knight to
E4 unless I knew for sure that I would
get to trade that Bishop off
now
I have to confess I had actually played
this position before uh and I was
mentioning earlier last year
but I was playing with black and I was
convinced black was doing great in this
line that's why I stopped playing it as
white I mean the engine says it's good
and then there were some
I think repertoire books that threw out
a couple of good lines and I think they
they mentioned
the move B4 here as uh as White's most
challenging move and then I looked at it
and I was like that's not such a big
deal
so I started playing it with black
and um I played against a very strong
player Grandmaster from Argentina
and
he actually
played this move against me
and I'd never seen this move before it
didn't really make that much sense to me
but I just played G5 which is obviously
the move white wants you to play and
then he went back and we played like
this uh normal looking benoni and all of
a sudden when I castled white played H4
and I was in trouble
and I I got a losing position out of the
opening I somehow won that game
but um
but it really got me thinking that
I misunderstood this position like it
was it's not nearly as easy as I thought
for black
so
I started taking a closer look and I
wasn't crazy about Knight H4 later I you
know I saw some some pretty convincing
ways of playing against it but the move
I really loved here was this move C5
it's just a beautiful little move
um because
it's so pure to the main thread like the
the structure
that that's present in the game what is
the idea of C5
the idea is to pursue this trade trading
minor pieces is so important that I'll
give you this Pawn
right that's kind of radical
um because it seems like it's a very
important Pawn it's what creates this
asymmetric structure
but
it's going to be worth it uh after let's
say black just goes for it right away
it's not the best move but uh it's not
the worst move so let's say
we you know we get to this position and
this is the harmony that I'm looking for
the Knight and Bishop
this is their ideal Arrangement the
Rooks are coming to E1 and C1 actually
not having a c Pawn might be a better
thing because now I have this pressure
against the Knight on C6 and my knight
is coming to C4 and E5 and my queen can
come to V3 and B6 Maybe
everything starts falling into place
very quickly so that's what I loved
about this position and that's kind of
you know where I was coming from
so my opponent castle and uh I made
rookie one I know this is happening
right so I'm I'm never worried about my
Pawn or anything
and now after Rook B8 I played Rook C1
by the way I think uh oh no I'm sorry I
played Knight D2 first
Rook B8 and now rookie one not Rook C1
so I'm just getting closer and closer to
my setup right all it's missing is my
Rook on C1 and I know that Knight's
coming to D6 and if Black's not careful
my other Knight's gonna come to C4 and
it's not going to be so easy you're not
even going to get a pawn now because I'm
going to have that incredibly strong
night
and there are actually some fascinating
games in the database you'll see some uh
you'll see white do some serious damage
in this position
so
I was very happy with the outcome of the
opening and as I was looking deeper and
deeper into the position
I started to really appreciate where
White is coming from here like this this
harmony among the minor pieces is uh as
we'll see
stronger than it looks
so my opponent plays B5
and his idea is actually quite logical
because if I don't take this Pawn then
I've lost control over the C4 Square
um black seems actually to be pretty
well set up on the queen side
and you know black can start looking at
ideas of B4 maybe bishop A6 seems like a
pretty reasonable game I mean I I have
to take on B6 and now after Rook takes
the point of this is that okay B2 is
hanging
and now
the move Knight C4 just seems
irresistible right so I mean it defends
B2 it attacks B6 puts the Knight on an
outpost uh it's a bad move
because after Rook B8
okay we've defended B2
but we've actually disrupted the harmony
among our pieces why because first of
all when The Rook comes to C1 now it's
going to be running into the night and
secondly we did nothing
to correct the position of the Knight on
e4 so instead of fixing one problem we
created another one and now we have two
so that's how you get tangled up in a
position you start playing sloppy
so we we have to kind of resist this
this urge to to play the obvious move uh
in fact the I play the move that I think
is the best move here which is Rook C1
and I defend the B2 Pawn indirectly
because if you take on B2 I'm just gonna
take on C6
and most importantly instead of putting
a knight on C4 I want to put a knight on
C5 this Knight on C5 is going to be much
more aggressive than the Knight on C4
sure a bit more unstable but hey that's
the name of the game in the benoni so
the knights coming to C5 which is going
to open up the position for the bishop
and uh as we'll see being
deeper into Black's position than let's
say a knight on C4 it's going to provide
all these interesting tactical ideas
so
uh
black plays 95 right kind of gets the
Knight off the hook
uh threatens Rook takes B2 threatens
Knight takes D3 this can be defended
pretty easily here the move Queen C2
also hitting the bishop on C7
and now after Bishop B8
my master plan is complete right look at
this position everything
is doing great everything
is optimized without really
stepping on anybody's toes so
here I think black started to realize
the position was a lot harder than it
looked and already
there are some threats floating around
that aren't obvious and after the move
Rook d8
um
Black's position is losing by force
so
this is kind of a an interesting moment
uh because
this is it I mean White's position has
been wound as tightly as possible right
and you know one more crank and the Jack
in the Box has to pop up so when you
can't
optimize your position anymore you know
that's when you need to to look for
tactics and
you know
it could be a very hard tactic I think
in this case it is a pretty hard tactic
or it could be very easy but the process
for finding them
is is usually the same you you have to
scan
the board for active moves right like
one of the biggest mistakes that you can
make is to all of a sudden fixate on a
move and just run with it as as far as
you can like I'm gonna try to calculate
the move F4 10 moves in advance
like F4 Knight G4 F5 you know like
that's sloppy calculation and
what if it doesn't work then you have to
start from scratch with another move so
you have to scan the board for your your
most active moves right your checks your
captures and your threats so yes you
know you would look at a move like F4
but you would also look at moves like
Knight A4 Rook takes E5 you know even if
they don't work or Knight C4 right all
of these moves or maybe Knight you know
B3 coming after this Pawn
so all of these moves make a lot of
sense because you know it asks the
question to Black like okay what are you
gonna do about this and if you have
a scatter plot of pieces
um it's usually going to be very hard to
solve those problems
so you know Rook takes E5 seems pretty
obvious not to work just Bishop takes
and what am I doing
um but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna throw
these ideas into trash right something
that's not good right now might be good
later so it's an idea that's floating
around
F4 uh
I would really be upset with myself
because
uh far from
you know trying to increase the pressure
on my opponent's poorly coordinated
pieces I'm just sort of luring them to
incredible squares right so I'm I'm
really just helping black so that moves
out and this move
I would much rather play Rook takes E5
than F4 right so that move
I'm very close to to throwing it in the
Dustbin
um
Knight B3 I remember was a move I
actually looked at during the game
because I was like how do you defend
that pawn on A5 I'll just go Knight
takes A5 B4 and the game is over but
actually you can defend that pawn very
easily
with Queen A7 and the Queen's actually
fine
on A7 in fact maybe uh black might play
A4 or Bishop D6 and things are getting
kind of messy
The Rook B5 so Black's Position will
fall into place
if I give him enough time
Knight C4 just trading off the night uh
doesn't seem to make sense maybe I'll
even blunder B2
so then I got around to looking at
this move
Knight A4
because now The Rook has to move the
Rook doesn't have a lot of squares
and uh
it seems like not only the only square
but actually a pretty good square is B5
this is
kind of like strange like the queen on
A7 was actually a good Square for the
queen well B5 is actually a pretty good
Square for The Rook too gets a lot done
defends A5 cover C5 covers ba E5
you got a lot of bang for your Rook
there uh so
I also want to be careful right I don't
want to play a move like decentralize my
knight
if it's going to improve the position of
my opponent's Rook it just doesn't make
sense
but sometimes just because it's a threat
you you know party is like oh maybe
you'll you'll miss it you know and you
kind of you have this impulse to do it
and in this case if you do
do it you have to justify it with a
variation it's okay to break the rules
as long as you have a good reason right
and here there's
there is a very good reason
and that is the move Queen takes C8
after root takes Rook takes
King H7
now I have
Rook takes B8
and after Rook takes B8 Rook takes E5
and I mean what happened right this was
actually all forced so
I don't know so far we're maybe like
four moves into the sequence
but
it was all with checks or captures and
the strange thing about this position is
just evaluating it right like if you
have to go back
here
right
I know I don't want to play Knight A4
Rook B5 unless I have some tactic right
the only tactic I have there is Queen
takes C8 so I'm sacking my queen and you
know then taking on B8 hopefully all
that's forced hopefully there's no in
between move Knight takes D3 at some
point right so that's kind of a question
that I have to answer as well
but then let's say black goes into all
of this and we get that Knight on A4
Rook on E5 three minor pieces for the
queen
now then we have to you know we're not
going to calculate our way through that
we have to rely on an instinct that's
telling us whether that is
good for us or not
and again it all comes down to Harmony
right because when you see the Knight on
A4 The Rook on E5 the bishop on G2 and
this Knight on D2 about to come to C4
and you know you see this Pawn on A5 and
you see this Rook that doesn't have an
open file right and it's not going to
have an open file either
then
you start to get a feeling of momentum
in White's position and usually when you
have that feeling it's that you're
the the Levee is broken and you're
completely dominating your opponent's
position
and this is actually what happened right
after Knight A4
takes takes uh this is a winning
position for white already threatening
A5 so
black plays Queen d8 and now Knight C4
right and black plays Rook C8 here
so
black is is understandably just playing
for for one shot you know knockout
tactics because
the long game is not going to be good I
mean here if I go Rook takes A5
you know then I'm just losing after Rook
takes E4 I don't have Rook A8 because of
Rook C1
and if Knight takes A5
this this is a move that that would
concern me because
it feels like you know we've been on the
thread of the game and then we just let
go right so
uh once you identify the threat of the
game you you have to think of it like as
writing a mechanical bull like you you
have to stay focused and on until the
last minute because you know if you get
distracted you're you know you're off
and and that's when bad things can
happen for example here maybe Rook C1
Bishop F1 Queen F6 and The Rook moves
away Queen F3 and now I'm losing so I
still need to keep my grip on the
position and that means that Pawns
aren't really what this game is about
here it's about domination right it's
about making sure that
these two very dangerous pieces are kept
under lock and key
so the move here is Knight B6
right hitting the Rook Rook goes back
right black would love to take here
and now just Rook B5 defending the
Knight just maintaining the position and
of course you know this uh
this point is always a Target right my
opponent here played F5 in order to
activate the queen
and um yeah there's really not
that much to do I mean A4 probably
rooked before and that's not going to
help
so the game
continued
A4
fixing the pawn but also defending my
Rook there were some tricks for example
here you know with A4 that I can't take
on A4 because my Rook is hanging and
actually during the game I was much more
concerned with A4 than than F5
because my main idea is to get rid of
the A5 pawn and push my passer and this
kind of sets me back more than F5
so I think here black mist his best
chance for counter play because
if he sees that my main thread my main
idea is to incorporate this Pawn as sort
of like
uh the guy that's going to win the game
for me
then you know
you can tell that A4 is is really the
move I don't know during the game I was
I wasn't gonna do I think
oh there was this bishop C6 idea that's
right it was kind of interesting because
now if
[Music]
um
if Queen C7
there was this move Rook C5
and you can't take on B6 because of
Bishop E4 check
so I get to untangle my pieces a very
nice way and now of course I will take
this pawn and then just go B4 B5 and all
of my pieces are just dominating too
so
yeah Bishop C6 was the move
um my opponent like I said played uh
F5
and after
A4 Queen G5 Rook takes A5
so
Queen C1 and Bishop F1 okay I mean
black has accomplished something here uh
he activated the queen sort of got it
Behind Enemy Lines and kind of messed up
my Bishop a little bit right I don't
want my Bishop there but the bishop does
make sure that nothing bad happens to
this D3 Pawn which means that nothing
bad will happen to this Knight on C4
which means that nothing bad will happen
to the Knight on B6
and now his idea is actually
to achieve some Harmony himself why not
uh
for example I'm just going to make a
move that really indulges what black is
trying to do right imagine something
like this
here here here here here here here
this was one variation that I remember
seeing during the game right as as a
possible illustration of
things I shouldn't do so
that seemed like an interesting starting
point for counter play
of course this move Rook B5 it's not
very good
um
I played
Rook E5
in this position which
now after
H4
uh
allows me to play A5 and this is going
to be different because after H takes G3
H takes G3 if black goes for that same
idea
with Rook h8 the point is that I have
Rook takes E6
and you don't have King G6 and you don't
have King G8 because then it'll just
trade off the rook and promote the pawn
and you also don't have ideas like Queen
H6 because the Rook is going to cover
that square as well so all of a sudden
this Rook E5 Rook takes E6 takes away
that entire source of counter play which
is already you know very thin for black
so
um
black played F4 which is a good try
uh unfortunately it just doesn't make it
right because if we just take the most
direct approach which is to go A6 and
continue marching that pawn down the a
file
after F takes G3 if I go f takes G3 this
is the harmony that black is looking for
this coordination between rook and queen
and all of a sudden I lost this game
right it's ridiculous
so
uh
the key
is disrupting communication between
these two pieces and the way of doing
that is by using White's Black's own
Pawn against them right because here
after G takes F3 of course I'm not going
to go King takes F2 allowing Rook f8 but
instead I'll go King G2
and this point really
is um
a hurdle that black can't overcome right
and you're out of time I'm threatening
A8 or a takes B8 so a lot goes for the
last shot right if I take the Rook on B8
I get mated in two moves
that would be very sad
but I can take on G3 and after Queen
takes Bishop G2 The Rook is now also
covering this source of counter play so
the centralized Rook I mean I remember
um
what I mean is it even fair to say like
one of my favorite chess shows I mean
there aren't that many
but uh your malinsky's every Russian
Schoolboy knows I mean he has these
lectures that are unbelievable
and funny and um one of them is The Rook
the best defender money can buy and it's
just so true like I never thought of it
that way and this Rook on E5 I mean it's
just holding everything together
and there's there's no fat in White's
position so that's kind of the beauty of
it
um because here
the last shot is really Rook f8 because
now if I'm careless and promote
after check King H2
check Bishop H3 here I have to Black has
to be careful because
if you go Queen F2 then this queen is
coming back to G2 and if you go Queen F4
I know Queen G3 and forget about it down
three pieces
uh
and if you go Rook F2
then I think I can just move my king
back because after Queen G3 Bishop G2
and the queen is also different and then
my next move is going to be Queen E4 no
matter what you play
so
it seems like oh maybe I just Queen
right wrong because black has this
killer
in between move Queen F4 to disrupt the
harmony right so this queen can't come
back now
after uh
King G2 just Queen F1
and I'm hitting you on these dark
squares and you just can't escape the
checks
uh
wait a minute is that right
here let me know
yeah Queen F4 King H1
oh okay I have this check
that's what I was missing
all right and then you make it back
right because King here
here that's the pattern huh
okay there we go
I had to work it out
so A8
great way to ruin a great game
uh just if you're going for all-out
greatness
but the key move here is uh Rook H5
so after Rook H5 uh the King has to move
and now the Rook drops back to H3 and
the point is that now you don't have
check on H4 right and after let's say
queen E1 King H2 you don't have any more
checks actually because the E5 square is
covered I'm promoting there's always a
check here The Rook like did its job on
E5 and then it drops back even more and
just starts taking care of business so
great example of the best defender money
can buy
um in the game black played Queen F2
right so maybe oh this was actually kind
of funny so my opponent really uh fought
till the very end
because here if I go King H2 there was a
cute variation that went Queen F4 and
now you think ah check I'll promote next
and after King H5 you promote
and let's say you know you take and now
King H4
and don't you have egg on your face
right
um
might even win this is black I don't
know
so the Kimu is King H1 and after King H1
he resigned because the only check left
is Queen E1 after King H2 again no more
checks so anyway I was actually pretty
happy with this game but I liked it
because uh it was able to illustrate
some fundamental ideas that involve you
know space and Harmony so anyway thanks
for listening